il doit en effet rencontrer le président
zelensky il se rendra avec le chancelier
allemand olaf chose avec mario draghi
également le président zelensky dans la
banlieue de kiev dans la banlieue de
kiev alors difficile d'avoir encore des
informations sur l'endroit exact puisque
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer pour des
raisons de sécurité il est très
difficile d'avoir le programme exact des
trois dirigeants puisque lorsqu'ils sont
arrivés ici on a pu voir ils étaient
accompagnés d'une escorte militaire ils
se trouvaient dans des voitures blindées
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il pourrait
peut-être se rendre ailleurs pinoit bout
de chats ou des exactions ont été
commises par les forces russes et puis
pour se rendre compte également des
dégâts des dégâts sur les immeubles
puisque ce sont des villes qui ont été
énormément bombardée par les forces
russes on sait que mon volodymyr
zelensky devrait accompagner le
président français emmanuel macron olaf
scholz et mario draghi lors de cette
visite dans la banlieue de kiev filet
les dirigeants les quatre dirigeants
devraient ensuite se rencontrer pour un
meeting ensemble et puis une conférence
de presse devrait être ensuite te donner
on attend évidemment sans doute des
annonces peut-être de la part de ces
trois dirigeants ce qui concerne
notamment la livraison d'armes puisque
vous le savez les ukrainiens réclament
quotidiennement plus d'armes aux
occidentaux la vice-ministre de la
défense encore dit il il ya quelques
jours que les ukrainiens n'avaient reçu
que 10 % des armes qu'ils réclamé aux
occidentaux ils disent les ukrainiens
qui pour gagner cette guerre ils ont
vraiment besoin d'armes et notamment
d'armes lourdes d'armes de longue portée
un mot sur la symbolique aussi de cette
visite d' emmanuel macron qui est là en
tant que président français mais qui est
là aussi également en tant que président
de l'union européenne vole audi mercedes
qui avait demandé à plusieurs reprises
au président de se rendre ici à kiev
avant la fin de cette présidence qui se
terminera fin juin il a donc fini par
être entendu et c'était vraiment une
une très très très important pour les
ukrainiens emmanuel macron en veut donc
envoyé un message fort en étant ici puis
le timing est parfait et si on peut dire
puisque demain la commission européenne
donnera un rendra son avis elle dira si
elle est favorable ou pas pour que
l'ukraine obtienne le statut de candidat
à l'union européenne
pauline bonjour on n'oublie pas non plus
le calendrier intérieur ici en france on
est entre les deux tours des élections
légistatives on y reviendra tout à
l'heure je voudrais pauline con qu'on
évoque peut-être ces malentendus ou en
tout cas ce malaise que des propos du
président français et ligne diplomatique
sur un fil ont pu susciter en ukraine et
les critiques notamment de celui qu'il
va rencontrer aujourd'hui le président
et d'un ski
oui il est vrai que kiev notamment
avaient très mal pris ce que emmanuel
macron avait dit en ce qui concerne la
russie il avait dit qu'il voulait
appeler à ne pas humilier la russie des
propos qui avaient été vraiment pas bien
pris ici à kiev ils se sont demandés
pourquoi
pourquoi emmanuel macron en fait
finalement continuer à garder et voulait
continuer à garder ce contact avec
vladimir poutine puisque il est vrai que
depuis le début de la guerre emmanuel
macron a eu plusieurs fois vadimir
poutine le président russe au téléphone
et c'est quelque chose qui a toujours eu
du mal à comprendre le président
volodymyr zelensky alors hier lors de sa
visite en roumanie il s'est également
rendu en moldavie le président le
président macron il a il a dit très
clairement il l'a répété la clarté de la
position française de soutien l'ukraine
sans aucune complaisance à l'égard de
moscou on peut imaginer qu'avec ses
déclarations emmanuel macron voulait
commencer à préparer le terrain avant
cette visite d'aujourd'hui à kiev